let's do some scale and indirect
measurement problems so they say use a
scale diagram to the right to determine
I think this is the scale diagram that
they're talking it's really above the
question and they want to determine
let's see the first the length of the
helicopter when they say the scale
diagram notice this helicopter it looks
pretty small I don't know how big your
screen is but you know looks a couple of
maybe one or two inches depending on
what resolution you're watching this
video on but they're saying this
helicopter is much bigger than that
they're saying just this little distance
right here just that little distance
that little white box there that's
actually a foot in the on the real
helicopter so what they're able to do is
draw a small version of the helicopter
and essentially give us a ruler to tell
us that that little distance is
equivalent to a foot and this whole
distance right here that whole distance
right there is equivalent to one two
three four five six seven feet did I get
that right one two three four five six
seven so this thing is equal to seven
feet so given that let's try to answer
their questions
so the first one the length of the
helicopter so that's from cabin to tail
is that distance right there let's see
how many of these things it is so if I
take that right there let me see if I
can copy and paste that so if I see if I
copy it then I paste it there's one
right there
one edit paste two right there then edit
paste and then we get not quite three
almost three but not quite we get about
that far so it looks like about two so
this right here is that's right here is
seven feet that right there is another
seven feet and I know that because that
is seven feet according to the scale and
then this looks like we got about that
far so looks like this is maybe not
another five feet if I were to estimate
actually we went to go all the way to
the end of the tail if we went to the
end of here it actually looks like
another seven feet we actually complete
three seven feet so I would say that
Part A I would go it to 27
feet sorry not 2721 feet seven feet
times three is equal to 21 feet
I'd go part one because if you go all
the way to this tippy tippy of the rear
rotor of the right there then you're
going to get 21 you're gonna get three
of these lengths let's do Part B the
height of the helicopter floor two
rotors so from here from floor two
rotors well I'll go from down here to
the rotors they might be talking about
this floor but who knows I think this
little so what is this distance right
here in feet what is that distance so we
could just eyeball a little bit they
didn't give us a vertical scale we could
just this scale looks like about that
high it looks about that high so that
looks that would be about seven feet so
let me copy and paste that so let me
copy it let me paste it so that would be
seven feet right there and then if I
were to do another one we're getting
about another half of seven feet so that
would be another three and a half feet
so I would say it is I would say that is
this is seven right there and then we
get about three and a half so seven plus
three and a half is ten point five ten
point five feet the length of one main
rotor I think the main rotor they're
talking about they're talking about this
length right there that length right
there that is the length of one main
rotor or actually this length right here
that is the length of one main rotor and
let's compare it to this scale over here
so let's compare it that's seven feet so
let's copy it and then let's paste it so
that is I know you can't I lost it so
let me copy it let me
copy and then paste so that's one length
so we want one rear rotor so that's
seven feet right there seven feet right
there and then we could do another one
the important thing is to get the idea
of it you don't have to get the exact
measurement we're not about to go out
there and build a helicopter so what is
this linked we have seven feet and then
we have one two three about another four
feet so I would go with Part C I'd go
with eleven feet for one rotor if this
is if we're getting to see this actually
head on maybe it's a little bit longer
if it's an angle but that gives us our
general idea actually looks a little bit
longer than that but yeah as long as you
understand how I'm using the scale is
the main thing the width of the cabin so
here that's the cabin with right there
this distance that distance right there
is the cabin width and if we compare it
to this right here we already said we
already said that this right here is
seven feet roughly edit copy paste so
that is seven feet that looks like about
the width of the cabin that's a good
estimate so the width of the cabin I
would say is seven feet and then finding
the diameter of the rear rotor system
the rear rotor system is this right here
that is the rear rotor system so if we
were to copy and paste our seven foot
length she let me copy and paste the
actual ruler so this is our actual ruler
so how long is the rear rotor system
let's look at our roller it looks like
one two three four feet is my best
estimate so I'd say the diameter of the
three rotor system is four feet so you
might have already known how to do this
but now you have a good sense look you
just what this there's this is telling
us that this little distance on the
picture is actually equivalent to a foot
and you just compare it to the actual
picture and you know how big the actual
helicopter is that's all that's going on
there let's do another scale and
indirect measurement problem so it says
on a Sunday morning the shadow of the
Empire State Building is 600 feet long
at the same time the shadow of a
yardstick which is
three feet long is one foot five and a
quarter inches how high is the Empire
State Building
so we could say height of Empire two
length of shadow so length of a shadow
should of empire of Empire should be
equal to taking the length of a
yardstick
so height height of yardstick I'm
assuming that they're pointing up the
yardstick like a skyscraper height of
yardstick divided by length of shadow of
yardstick now this problem looks a
little bit hairier because we have feet
here then we have one foot five and a
quarter inches and you do everything in
inches and do everything in feet and the
interesting thing is here you can look
at the units as long as we calculate
this in feet and we calculate this in
feet down here these units are going to
cancel out if you have you know X feet
divided by 600 feet in this case the
feet are going to cancel out you'll have
a unit list quantity so it's really just
going to be a pure ratio same thing here
and you could do it in feet or you could
do it in inches and you could actually
do this in feet and do this side and
inches because you get feet divided by
feet the feet cancel out the inches
cancel out so they stay unitless so it
actually becomes a lot easier when you
can keep the right side in inches and
you can keep the left side and feet so
let's say the height of the Empire State
Building is X so we could say X feet
over the length of the shadow the shadow
of the Empire State Building is 600 feet
over 600 feet is equal to the length of
a yardstick standing up with a height of
a yardstick let's do it inches three
feet long it's 36 inches 36 inches and I
want to show you that the units work out
36 inches divided by the length of its
shadow one foot five and a quarter
inches what's that one foot is 12 inches
two
plus five and a quarter is 17 and a
quarter or 17 0.25 inches and notice the
units cancel out feet divided by feet
inches divided by inches so they just
become pure ratios x over 600 is equal
to 36 over 17 0.25 the reason why I
could use feet here and inches here is
because the unit's cancel I don't want
to make that very very very clear now we
can just cross the multiply which is
essentially just multiplying both sides
of the equation by 617 point two five so
17 point two five times X 17 point two
two five times X is going to be equal to
36 times 600 times 600 and then we can
divide both sides by 17 0.25 divided
both sides by 17 point two five so X is
equal to 36 times 600 over 17 point two
five and let's get the calculator out so
X is equal to 36 times 600 divided by 17
point two five is equal to 1250 2.2
let's just round it so X is equal to
1250 2.2 feet which is almost a quarter
of a mile so the Empire State Building
is pretty high but this was pretty neat
because this is something that you could
actually do you could actually measure
the shadow of a skyscraper and then you
could actually measure the shadow of a
yardstick and then doing that you can
actually figure out the height of a
skyscraper which is pretty neat because
other way you know if you didn't do know
how to do this math you'd have to get
into a helicopter and drop a huge I mean
it'd be a much harder thing to do so
hopefully you found that pretty
interesting